after about a day of deliberations in a
wrongful death lawsuit against republic
services this morning a jury found the
driver julio cortez solano negligent in
the death of an 11-year-old las vegas
girl good afternoon thank you for
joining us at 4 i'm kirstjen joyce and
i'm christian casadas victoria saha
joins us live with the details of the
verdict and how a grieving mother plans
to move forward victoria
jasmine espana was only 11 years old
when she was trying to cross the
sidewalk here sorry the crosswalk here
at viking and sand hill road and while a
driver from republic services was also
trying to cross that driver failed to
yield and a jury today found that
jasmine was also at fault
jasmine's mom and consonant espana
filed a wrongful death suit against
republic services her attorney asked for
65 million dollars in damages after a
two-week trial and almost two days of
deliberation the jury awarded her 38.8
million dollars jurors found republican
services driver julio cortes solano to
be negligent in jasmine's death they
also found jasmine partly to blame as
she entered the crosswalk without
looking where public services was found
negligent in hiring training and
retaining cortes solano jasmine's mother
said through a translator she hopes this
is the start of change for the company
and she says that she forgave him
the attorney for the espana family
wanted the driver to pay punitive
damages but the jury decided against it
i did reach out to republican services
regarding the verdict they sent a
statement saying quote we extend our
heart filled condolences to family and
friends of jasmine espana this was a
tragic accident republic services has
always maintained a strong culture
committed to safety and best in class
safety programs and will continue to do
so they also say they are unable to
comment further on
litigation excuse me reporting live
victoria saha 8 news now